[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody Oh happy Wednesday
I'm John Luke and this Joey and we're
playing Wednesday the 21st Wednesday of
the 21st not Friday the 13th I mean
really like laser is there another
Friday the 13th this year uh it's in
October actually right because yeah
even with then comes out yes everybody
welcome to uh this Friday the 13th
livestream the apology update I guess
yeah it is um so apparent like I'm sure
if you had played the game when it was
released you know that went through a
little bit of a rocky start with their
server problems and just general like uh
just dissatisfaction between the the
gaming like the fans so this is a the
developers kind of yeah like apology as
you said right so supposedly it's been
fixed and they've added a couple new
things some some counselor outfit so why
don't we check those out yeah so each
counselor has a two sets of new clothes
do it so indigent - they're the regular
one right here you go scroll all the way
to the end they have a couple different
colors here very 80s track suits like
this one though that's cool yeah and so
that each like every counselor has two
home who do you play who do I play my
main and uh I don't know I haven't
thought about that maybe I guess shed is
a good good person cane by the way uh
chat I am gonna be looking at it so if
you have any questions I want to talk to
uh say hi
feel free we also got a couple GameSpot
people in our party we're going to be
starting up in a second um the other
thing they added so they added a bunch
to give or when a bunch of sikhi right
yeah they're plaque Chua lee i from what
i believe you can see that we don't have
a yet it's supposed to be 13,000 but i
think they're waiting until the double
xp weekend yeah right this weekend to
give it out to everyone and of course
the yeah
checkerboard like that actually like her
cause she's good at repair let's get
some purple shoes there we go
of course the big thing is
Jason yeah okay like that
is he different like ability wise no so
he still has the same abilities right
here is it just a part three Jason yeah
so part three you can write you can
change in and voila
recho Jason which is that's supposed to
be the the nest game right yeah so cool
I like purple yeah I'm gonna I'll keep
them there
got goob in the chat sup bro sup goose
up alright let's get this party started
man let's go
I don't got Robin maybe he'll join later
yeah oh yeah oh good another room Oh
Corey says is this retro Jason skin is
it just skin non-exclusive Jason looks
like it's just the skin not doesn't
actually change the way Jason operates
hopefully it's about Xbox one so I saw
yesterday on the on it's supposed to be
for all consoles this update but on
Twitter they were saying that the update
this update went live late last night
for ps4 and PC but apparently the Xbox
update got delayed too later today so if
you're playing on Xbox one you should be
getting the update today I can go check
out their their Twitter they post
updates on that kind of stuff
oh no it looks like a Jake was replaced
by a little German boy nein wait we lost
Jake yeah did he leave early he probably
got kick
oh we do another one uh no kyboot
someone I don't think they're the
ability to that's fine we'll get him in
ah
eventually all right yeah let's just get
the skipper thing going wait
oh good man yeah get Jake in getting
here Jake 13 seconds go that's okay we
got jaws of the Apocalypse and said he
wants to know do they fix the server
issues supposedly although this is our
first time playing since then so we will
find out we got Nick margarita also in
the party yep was James and the chat
seems excited that Nick's in the party
yeah okay here we go I don't want to
Higgins Haven someone stuff we think
this game is worth the price I how much
is it now a little boring it's 40 bucks
still I think like there hasn't been
sale for you maybe I don't know um the
full price for tea I don't think so
personally
I know I feel like there's just not like
a lot of your enjoyment for the game
relies on your ability to communicate if
you're a counselor um so it can be
really hit or miss if you like if you
like playing solo a lot good putting $5
on Nick being the first to die uh well
let's see who is is this person the does
that mean they're Jason no I don't think
it picks yet like you don't know Oh till
it starts I hope it's me Yeah right we
want to see that wreck cool definitely
at the very least everyone's playing
retro Jason right all right here we hold
on our favorite part oh no they're not
playing retro Jason so this is not us
that knew not well at least hopefully
everyone else has the uh yeah there we
go
all right we got the custom skin at
least five minutes later anyone else get
away all right where is my tan ago going
so far I'm higher oh yeah Jim's comp
Cornwell says that the Steam sale starts
tomorrow you don't call you don't say
James Cromwell yes I almost did say
James Cromwell is that a real person
yeah that's probably the babe farmer Oh
ah speaking of which we are in my lovely
farm well uh Nick got kicked so gube was
kind of right he's the first one he's
first one to go he was the first one to
go and I think that also answers boobs
other question seems like there might
still be some server issues woo I can
hear something it's okay I got a trip
right there but yeah the James was
making a good point that supposedly the
spring was confirmed at this point the
scene sale is starting tomorrow yeah and
so uh the game might be on sale then and
that might be a good chance to pick it
up hard to say sometimes games I've like
just come out or on sale but sometimes
they are or if they are they're not for
that much my team if this game is you
know what I would say if this game is 15
20 bucks and a bunch of your friends
pick it up with you that could be some
pretty good like a weekend of really fun
energy yeah it's just a weekend yeah
that's a bang yeah I have a friend who
um huge horror fan and was like really
excited for this game and if he
eventually ends up picking it up this
person has a some new clothes apparently
oh okay oh this is I don't think I've
seen that counselor before oh oh no do
Jason run I'm a little tired right I
hate that mechanic get him yeah later
nice did that like regen your stamina
home think so just went back okay oh my
back of the barn damn it
heading that hidden that okay yeah head
in the big header this it achievement
for jumping out the second-story window
oh [ __ ] yeah he's get in there get in
there
I'm gonna go out like a champ down the
second-story window come on please regen
mine I'm hoping they just fixed some of
the weird Oh No
yeah gal that window jump out it jump
out it jump out it jump out it later see
he can't go out windows remember right
okay I'm also injury hit me on the way
out and my entire team is a little bit
somewhere else oh hello oh come on
already
let's see what he has now yeah all right
I don't know if I want them to fix that
stuff well just kinda like the general
janky nosov like some of the kills yeah
I'm kind of a mixed bag for me little
German boy nein yeah it's a good name
like that stuff with the ragdolls pretty
funny but then stuff like I kept trying
to like close a door and it wouldn't or
the doll yeah open like that stuff no
it's not seem to be doing an okay job
it's kicking me I was standing in a
corner yeah little drummer boy we're
just going can hear the music going off
here right
what are they doing just waiting for
death he's out of there I think
oh shoot your flare dude brain to spit
all right well you messed up man that
was on you don't we broke free
I don't think okay yeah yeah sure go
pick up [ __ ] hit it come on look all
right I'll go back to him okay don't do
it is he gonna do it dude yeah that
doesn't really okay
it stuns them for a little bit okay guys
might not wouldn't just stand there no
I'll pick up the flare
let's watch them die though go that
person oh it's the backbreaker
oh no all right just the pickup and toss
onto the ground I'm surprised this
person did not
maybe yeah why they might be invisible
to them oh do you think it's one of
those glitch things whoa hmm they're
moving now we're moving now lion Jason
kill them feels like I'll save her for
later
maybe yeah well messed up dude I don't
know how you kill Jason it's you're
supposed to be able to if you do enough
damage to him there's like oh man this
guy do we want to mute the mics
maybe yeah they will do that after this
uh if you tab I think you can pull up
yeah I think you can I can't do that
right now really uh okay
start recording start the start
recording he yeah why not
come on guy oh he's the only one left
GUP says that kid should be in school
now a man no goob it's summertime which
guy
George kid the one chattin oh the chip
sound like kid but nah goob it's
summertime summertime parents are at
work perfect time to play he hears I
13th he's running is he on yeah that's I
think that's the thing you I don't want
to run too much oh this guy's got
throwing knives right yeah so if you run
your stamina meter goes down yeah if you
stop before it completely drains it
fills pretty quickly
yeah but if you let it drain all the way
it's pretty much a death sentence at
that nice that'll work really nice
that's okay he's got a first-aid spray
were you gonna go oh back to the camp
campfire come on you want to do that he
knows you're gonna oh just a matter of
time dude get that floating bear trap
there you go yeah put it down he's
walking right well he wants to hear
what's a loo room but you want to put it
right there because okay you just walk
around it dude I don't think it's gonna
work anything
ah whoa oh he did on purpose
CCS well-played little German that guy
was not German decidedly not oh really
I'm strange
I'll admit that's a good way to go out
of like you can't get me Jason yeah I
kill myself I was trying to see we can
get the guys in here yeah let's see no
Rob still doesn't look like it they're
gonna leave match yeah Roy says have you
guys attempted to kill Jason at all in
the office I don't think we've ever made
yeah yeah we've attacked him quite a bit
what yeah we've like ganged up on but I
think there's like a very specific I've
seen a couple videos on it there's a
very specific way to kill him apparently
oh I assumed it was just if you
eventually deal enough damage like you
have to get him you have to stun him
with something a player or something
from what I remember there was a there
was a sweater that you can you can take
the mom sweater and wear it and that
will like just on him weird cuz you know
how in them in the movies that's what
happens like the the girl puts on the
sweater right right and he just gets
like he goes into a trance because he
remembers his mom or whatever like you
put that on and then use like a shotgun
I think with Tommy Jarvis or it was like
an axe maybe to chop off his head that
you're saying interesting so one of
those things doesn't make sense he would
you want to it be the way it happens in
the movie yeah all right let's turn down
the voice volume all right let's try
going one more time for Nick come on get
in here
oh sweet all right comfy were saying
so some was saying the the little um the
red on the on the minimap non on the
main map um on the character when I was
showing all the characters and there was
like that red and we thought is that guy
the register triangle right yeah
apparently that just means their host
okay their host yeah cuz I don't think
these are these are all dedicated
servers Oh which i think is also part of
the issue with why this game like
dedicated servers are never good
because it's all dependent on the
connection of that host yeah someone's
asking when is this come on Xbox the
games already on on Xbox as far as the
update supposedly sometime later today
the real McCoy says do you guys ever
invite viewers um I
I've always entertained the idea of
doing it it's really tricky though yeah
just kind of gain everyone on the same
page
I think the the the because it takes so
much time and work I find the easiest
way to do it would be when you have a
game where it's just a lobby invite
where it's like okay I created a lobby
here's the name of the lobby and here's
like the password or something yeah
anyone in the chat who wants to join
come join that Lobby I think that's the
easiest way to do it because it's just
um you don't have to deal with like
everyone sending you an invite then you
gotta like kick people out right it was
a joint it just takes so much time and
you're not playing the game but I'm
definitely into the idea of wanting to
play with like people watching like
absolutely
commander Jane Shepard know the lobby is
not happening this week normally be
happening right now but uh post e3 we're
all pretty we're taking a break taking a
week with the lobby it'll be nothing not
to mention we just got all the equipment
back from e3 yesterday so right we don't
think yesterday they just got back today
like yeah we're definitely I mean we
could have done it without taste we got
everyone in suite will they stay in
that's the question who weren't packing
a collage actually I think I like this
one the best the map
all right bucket fire back at thee I
wouldn't call unprofessional from what
it sounds like in the chat in their
their tweet I think they were planning
on updating them all at the same time I
think there's just some extra issues
with the Xbox yeah but to take a little
bit longer I'm not they don't really say
what but I imagine they would you know
very much try and do it no its own face
again I don't know if I'd want them to
fix that or not I don't think I would
come on y'all playing on the oh yes we
did it
okay so it doesn't show in the cutscene
TRO Jason I'll know this is just
ridiculous looking but I like it
alright let's go kill some camp I like I
like go kill some council dommage to the
the terrible yeah alright so do I
remember how to play this
alright I can warp yeah do that this
default Jason right this is a pretty
tree yeah now is that's default right no
it is it's the first Jason because it's
the most iconic but that is the thing
about Frye the 13th is that you actually
you don't see Jason until well you don't
see Jason told part two and in part two
he's wearing the bag over his head oh
right right so the Jason that everyone
thinks of and knows of is part three
Jason yeah which is which is kind of a
little weird right to think that the
iconic Jason didn't happen till the
third movie alright guys where are you
all right that could uh they've been
here it's a couple doors open who is a
bunch of uh hello
I see him hello I want to put trap down
here oh man I just think about the last
game that we played when I was chasing
and uh I had that trap with who did I
trap I think I was robbed like I just
put them all out of every single window
he jumped out is a wonder in the
livestream yeah that was a good house a
good live stream ooh
grab a throwing knife there you go
another one here oh I do not know how to
pronounce your name but uh in the
youtube check so they just sub thank you
very much
appreciate it knock that door down
alright okay I'm already halfway out oh
yeah someone has already called Tommy
what come on that was really quick but
like - Carl Tommy wanted us to yeah get
him oh I need to grab him the other
issue I have with the stand oh damn that
not him I don't think so hmm okay
another one where we saying oh is that
there are a lot of like cool create
kills you can do but they require you to
like be around a certain object yeah you
pick them up it's like you you want to
then walk over to that object right
right by the time you get to that object
they can get free so it's always easier
just to grab them in immediately like
you know snap their neck yeah back or
something
I mean it so it's also a lot more
entertaining I don't know like putting
their head to fire is pretty cool like I
want to do that yeah oh yeah I'm talking
he was like all purple Jason light you
turned off voice I thought I did too
now whatever is fine
I do like that he closed the door on me
I'm coming back
oh sorry sirs that was the cops not
Jarvis come on man
fireplace fireplace - fireplace as well
talking about yes yeah awesome
Oh that'll learn you see that's rad that
is this stuff like that that's really
cool but normally it's just like more
convenient to just snap there yeah cuz
like y-yeah by the time you get over
there
they've already kind of wiggled their
way out well know that I feel like
that's just what makes it more like
horse a is fine ooh somebody just uh far
don't asked when did the singleplayer
come out I heard they're adding a
single-player component with the full
physical release oh really
they're gonna do a physical yes and that
will be $60 oh wow yeah not sure I feel
about that actually I do know how I feel
about that oh where is everybody real
McCoys ten kills are my favorite yep
there's um oh the tenth one's the the
sleeping bag one is really good because
it's um it's just an homage to my
favorite kill in all a Friday the 13th
movies where Jason just takes someone
out of a grabs them out of her sleeping
back in their tent drags them out and
then hello surprised them to death I can
sew a wall or a tree oh oh yeah I just
got it on to do it it's okay it's fine
yeah push them into the lake
okay maybe was that uh was that Nick I
just saw Nick in the chat yep Nick
sorry Nick alright let's go - there's
some stuff going on right here
see I'm unlocking the alternate kills I
feel like it's pretty key to not having
this not be boring yeah when you Jason I
mean that's all it's not like he can
unlock any uh any better abilities it's
just they uh someone here yeah it's just
like more entertaining yeah
kills I mean he's definitely gone out
the altar yeah good Oh someone brought
up a good point so that that radio was
the cops that means the cops are at the
entrance so they're all gonna try and
flee to the cop yeah so we have to try
and get there before them and wait for
them where's the entrance oh it's good
question one of these I guess one of
those let's see see if this guy runs
come on is he in there well no let me do
this for a quick just for fun oh yeah I
thought I could burst through it like
walk through it I think you could see
hmm
hey that's not the right door is he in
here no mmm Oh throwing knife alright
let's get to that entrance then okay Oh
which was supposedly there still I don't
think that's them right I think it is or
isn't it I could be wrong hello cops are
here ops yeah get to the cut yeah I'm
gonna go over here
well they're all over the place it
doesn't necessarily mean it's them it's
just sound is what that is there's one
uh-huh see you know I guess get him get
him
oh very nice oh really hard aim oh wait
nah man yeah there is they're getting
away they got away oh they'll guide you
hello hello sir Jim Oh No brush it off
brush it off ah no well played get him
get him grab him yeah
[Music]
wait I'm okay Oh with city hoodoo got
left I can't be everyone right no that's
not one okay I'm gonna get at least one
more this guy right there get wait wait
wait a second what traps yeah or they
can go around huh I don't think I think
they still have to go a little bit he's
waiting though is he the only one left
oh yes kill him kill him do it
no oh we put yet enough right yeah
sadness no all right
yeah okay well he's happy good for him
good for him ah I - I got to sad Jason
here
I'll admit though I've never seen the
camp counselors yeah whoever well
whoever was playing they knew what they
were doing unlike me or unlike us during
the last dream when yeah Jason and you
just like because they have a couple of
the the later counselors unlocked yeah
apparently Nick's the one who called the
police
damn it Nick but he's the one who died
so at least we got him yeah oh we got
the bookish girl all right we go for
about half an hour let's try not okay
and the old man blew he says the red the
red spots are my traps oh I forgot about
those
okay okay I'm gonna switch to which
bookish girl offer
she's like the nerdy ones Delft which
has stealth your sweater so now the
colorful houndstooth which got some
ballet flats is that what that pattern
is called house dude yeah okay I never
knew what that was called I see usually
it's a black and white and not less so
colorful she got lost stealth and she
got repair and five out of ten composure
which is not bad
did uh some cheeks not in here
did he not end up in did he get kicked I
think got kicked maybe halfway through
is there anyone else in Gothic Jake he's
margaritas in here we're at Crystal Lake
am i I hope that is not gonna be me can
you do that as a not as a stab with the
pole you can do that with a pole but not
while they're in bed I don't think
there's anyone sleeping you can wait no
actually if you're hiding under the bed
yeah you could do that but you can't
like decide to have sex with another
camp counselor no mid-game that would be
weird
like what gameplay justification like
okay I know you're running from Jason
you two need to stop and have sex well
like what would that give you a give you
wear stamp full of Dreams just it would
drain your stamina I was drained
everything okay this guy's not this guy
could be he could be though nine maybe
ooh okay gotta go play it safe here I am
bookish after all you're very learn it
Oh check that uh we got all Orphic I'm
just gonna close it well this is only
useful though if you use the voice chat
though oh the radio yeah gives the ideas
and you can then communicate with yeah
got some good stuff whoa
she's already uh someone here he's
already calling the cops or something
really yeah uh-oh me too much noise yeah
I think she just called the cops
nice I've never seen the phone before
or maybe I haven't understand it I could
do anything with it right I am gonna go
oh I have a map yes
where am i okay I'm gonna go you're
going that way go to the bathroom
okay wait check pull up the thing again
no margarita oh he left no oh I got
booted ding all right well we're in this
on on our own seems like there's still
some some issues okay apparently she
called Tommy not the cops
Oh God yeah goop this is a Cosby sweater
unfortunately well thanks for running
sweaters Cosby I got kicked again all
right anything good here yeah guys we
can confirm that there still seems to be
some issues with the servers got Aaron
Rodgers Hail Mary arm
it's guys just singing now thank you
oh thanks where's everyone else okay we
go yeah relatively close who Tommy
Jarvis is here that means no one already
died right no we know we called him
right but isn't it a dead player becomes
Tommy oh you're right
no oh so one way killed killed one of
eight oh it doesn't say who Oh probably
this guy yeah whoever is Tommy
T&T man TNT man looks like I met this
alone which objects better like for the
weapons yeah I have no idea
oh yeah here's the hiding under the bed
yes check which a chastity used to great
effect during one playthrough she get
killed eventually but she hid there the
entire time we have that nothing what
about in uh this is just a small small
where's everyone else everyone so spread
out well I want to go over to that car
right yeah that's we want to run focus
on oh okay we're good we're good
good hurry low musical scene
curious says where did you get the game
from we're playing this on the PC right
now on Steam but it is available on ps4
and Xbox one as well if you're
interested in picking it up alright we
got Kevon in here
oh hello Kevin what's up I don't think
my push-to-talk is it enabled sorry hmm
nother map already got that oh sorry I
was trying to go into the bed dude as
bad not risking hopefully just chases
that guy
[Music]
seems safe gamer dude asks if it's out
for Xbox update not sure supposed to be
out today but I cannot tell you if it is
currently out okay I think oh oh okay
I'll just clearly grab that spray dude
oh that was weird right that like sound
you know what the hill okay
this cars right here I'll have anything
for you but I just are checking houses
then just nothing in that one where'd
everyone go
there's like a bunch out there are
usually it's kind of close kind of close
at least in my experience someone in the
twitch chat is saying the update is not
out for Xbox one so go get it yeah if
you're playing out for Xbox go get that
update man get your get your retro Jason
and your you're sick bookish girl
sweater
where is everything well it's like
someone already jumped through this one
huh something happened that's it what's
in there yeah no grab it grab that other
uh med kit
oh oh oh she seems unfazed by I don't
think she sees it which is good because
then she won't make any noise I'm just
gonna close this door right here please
before she gasps yes yeah there it is
got some gas uh they're not gonna hear
me Oh fine we're fine we're fine we're
fine fine oh yeah here we go
oh no no
Oh hit the wrong button
wait oh whoops cool he's okay he seems
alright just laying there it's chilling
we need tuckered out
oh we need keys oh [ __ ]
alright that's alright we got the first
aid yeah good I'm good I'm good let's
check this one I hear some screaming
well no one's in this one right now
all right pick up a wrench who actually
machetes better think it's a tree branch
definitely that was a Zelda where the
keys at the keys are the hardest right
there
no those keys work all right yeah you
think they would or like that's where
they put it
I feel like since I have the radio I can
hear them but I turned off voice Chen
che turn the back on no because we could
hear that guy yeah but only when he was
close
oh it was weird okay anything over here
no maybe yeah maybe like I'm just doing
this all solo
oh man someone already escaped whoa oh
they probably took the boat it's a boat
gone it might be Liz this frying hand
[ __ ] there's one wait
yeah someone yeah someone took the
motorboat oh no let themselves so this
is me and Kevin someone got hacked
shattered and his jaw ripped off can't
take this canoe right yeah just Li push
it out swim away
I don't think you're gonna find anything
here yeah we need the battery and the
keys sorry Kevin I can't hear you I feel
like I should be helping him in some way
yeah do you want turn back on the voices
yeah we'll just do it just for now oh we
won't build a communicate back but if I
if I die during this menu will be very
unhappy
oh there's so much what so much of the
camp that I need to explore in order to
find the keys really no uh it's the
objective to kill Jason to survive in
this case definitely not to be able to
camp right now yeah it's just me and one
other guy oh no just me
perfect how long have you been going for
oh I don't know
whoo what's that what's not that nothing
set him on fire okay what do we got in
here I already been in here was a
machete which we already have on the
radio not gonna help
hmm
this is gonna be tricky cuz I'm the only
one alive no idea where to go this is
based on the movie I'm kind of I mean
it's not like recreating these specific
events of one movie yeah it's more just
taking the environments from multiple
the movies and multiple Jason's and kind
of letting you run loose that Kevin
where how's he a dead body oh hello
hello back his ghostly spirit I hear
some hacking
sheet Oh
all right let's look at the map for a
sec while we're in here Oh No Oh your
hair oh god what's happening your hair
little way to go rip it off oh no it's
just an absent totally just destroys and
Nick damn it one got away I think I'll
go check the boat damn it
oh man alright let's do one more do you
want to try and get Nick back in yeah
let's try going back in I'll leave this
on my Jiro's fireplace is still the best
kill some are lucky number 13 definitely
agree about that that was the highlight
kilter 13 counselors how was the
highlight the fireplace kill oh yeah
definitely take a look at the other
counselor stuff I miss anyone shad
like the white shoes it's classy
Margareta J gave up I assume right yeah
up probably let me just jump it jump
back in I'll invite him if he not only
that if you can get in here what else
yeah we need a sleeping bag he'll that's
what we need I'd like that
mmm do I still have yep still retro
Jason ooh I can put we can do have
enough for 2x1 who I do give a head
punch I got a head place is it just
random which of these three you get no
so off so you can pick four at a time
let's do head stomp but but light of the
four you have activated is it random no
so whenever you grab someone you have
the ability of choosing these four with
the keys here oh I didn't know that oh
okay that's why did the the nice nap
last time he also has a backbreaker
I like the head punch head punch is good
Oh actually I won't get heart punch Oh
like through the yeah it's just straight
through how we're really not gonna get
Jason if we do it'll be worth it
hmm
come on guys ready up how do I get retro
Jason free update part 3 Jason e3 ok
turns back down who might be too late
what about the money that comes later
all about the money
oh we can watch locks 76 putting there
for their Twitter chat up there if you
want to watch multiple perspectives
people that'd be pretty cool get eight
of them at once
and then Jason the set up probably
wouldn't be worth it but I mean I always
thought it'd be cool to like with these
kinds of games or we are recording
everyone screens
yeah then we could like switch
dynamically between each one yeah we
could certainly do that require a lot of
setup on on eight pcs are you thinking
though yeah it'd be like eight pcs all
set up it's too it's too much frankly to
do that not worth the effort yes a lot
come on cert reek
ooh he's got the the Savini Jason I
don't know yeah did you get that whoa no
I think it you have to my need to unlock
it somehow I remember seeing that though
looks really cool yeah I'm get Jake in
here
you never know we're dropping like flies
we're good
so it says is a Kickstarter was it it's
it's a is a Kickstarter oh the game
no no well the game was but the the
Sabini Jason I think oh it's like a
bonus Kickstarter bonus so little late
alright there we go
damn Savini skills go for 300 bucks oh
well guess you'd get a code and then
you'd damn that's crazy so we need just
skin that yeah I'm pretty sure it's just
skin that's not a alternate alternate
Jason alternate Jason we're like
alternate I don't think you get any
extra abilities hey hey you margarita is
that you so I asked what's your favorite
movie um Jason movie Jason moving um I
want to say it the problem is is when I
try and think about them like they all
kind of blur together at some point so
they were like which one's from which
movie is a bit tough but I don't
remember like well oh hello I'm in the
room now um I remember three and four
being pretty good crap okay in that
radio I don't always get the radio of
course I would get it in the one without
a voice chat oh they're just talking
general scary movies
gube says Joey was about to say what
women want true that's the best horror
movie I've ever seen
can you imagine that though being able
to hear woman's thoughts all the time
without like stopping it nothing you can
do a true nightmare or just anyone's
thoughts to use it's like an that uh
that's seen Bruce Almighty when he's
getting all the prayers right yeah okay
let's go
I want the state to close like I turn on
the radio far as my favorite horror
movie um one of my favorite movies of
all time is uh John Carpenter's The
Thing yes
Armus Oh better yeah that is not one of
my favorite is a car great I need
someone with a map shoot oh there it is
oh nice guys I got the battery I know
you can't hear me a couple you were
saying actually get some new powers with
the Savini skin so it might actually be
the written a fall on different Jason oh
dude no I got back up back up
whoa whoa boy
I'm just gonna crouch right here we are
a bookish girl who's master of stealth
which is probably how we didn't notice
this yeah way oh no one yeah that's
right no wonder I live so long last time
cuz I was just walking around I hear
stuff going on you might be trying to
destroy the car you think you could do
that can't do that I know he can once
it's right yeah once they're driving oh
you're mashing intimately familiar with
that experience alright oh [ __ ]
that's Locke now might be good am I good
I don't know I'm doing it I'm doing it
go for it no well play Jason oh hey what
have to hold it whoops yeah we're good
we're good we're good
well he has traps all over the place
they have gas now they got a flare me
guess
anything in here
okay I don't think there's anything well
I'm just on the opener tonight
dude he's right on yeah who is that
Louise on yeah yes he's on he's right
back
go Joey out the window
no you jumped that wait I'm okay yeah
Shh that was a little not taking any
chances
see he has no idea where I am he has no
idea he's gone he teleported yeah he
laughing cool he booked it yeah whoo ah
wait why is it gray
I think you're bleeding out
I don't know why it's gray you be
bleeding out
no think so come on right these are some
firecrackers so you are bleeding to
death
wonderful oh no colors coming back think
I'm alright okay we're okay we're okay I
do have a lot of scratches all over my
sweater and they oh that face oh geez
it's just a 30-foot fall no worries skál
the first n is asking about the the free
CP we're thinking they're saving that
for the free xp weekend yeah that's why
I was reading on the message boards on
Steam did they lock all these doors okay
I'm going in here
all right let's hope there's this
first-aid spray but we got no cars
repaired dude get to that car I'm trying
off only we have the radio or mics uh
Aaron was saying we're not bleeding to
death our fear was maxed all right
because we were probably around Jason
too long cars repaired yeah I forgot
that fear is a thing in the game even
though they don't really show it yeah
there's no meter for it so I felt more
scared you are like the more you'll I
guess trip like she is maybe the more
noise you'll make well you know we
probably still have the keys though
this is me this is her being scared
right now
how do we look perfect dude bookish
girls got it made though with this stell
does he know can he see dude Alva he
knows don't move don't move keep riding
though not moving okay he left he left
he left
ho ho ho bookish girl group says books
ROP they are knowledge yo know we need
the key
yeah they're probably okay well this
Jason's like hanged oh they're running
over there you see even in the distance
I need a key blower army hello thanks
for joining
yeah I wonder what she looks like
like when Jason like looks around does
he just see nothing great
yeah you're the main cabin now right
shoe enough the cars moving that car is
moving but you only they left without
weight that kind they live without that
guy too
oh there's a Jason dude Jason's right
there oh he's trying to chase it yeah
he's going after it
oh well hey psycho wolf you know what I
hope he gets those guys yeah hope they
die it was also kind of scared
well we radioed for Tommy Jarvis he's
here he's still alive
somebody escaped I assumed it was the
guy in the car I do you think it was
just one dude yeah like he found the
keys everything else was good um someone
says cyborgs man says try reasoning
Jason reasoning yeah I don't think
that's gonna work get into a nice debate
with him well hold on hold on Jason uh
you might need to rethink couple things
she said what are you doing with your
all I just think about like going okay
where look where we are
wait what are you doing man wait wait
you're what are your overarching goals
you kill us and then what well there's
some keys to how do you get in before
there's probably multiple keys so you
gotta grab that her stage fright I'm
trying is it just a fake one no it's
it's a shining of you crouch
now you definitely want the Flair well
hello there yeah just push down all the
way yeah just yeah there we go that is
oh oh and that's so fun you pick it up
and like spray me that's a good question
cuz it's here
dude that is that socks for another one
somewhere please there's gotta be a
second car right there's usually two
cars the two cars I want to say most
aligned I'm following this guy two cars
yeah I definitely follow him tree branch
hmm Tommy pretty go now here Dave oh
he's in the back he bailed on you
nobody's sticking around bookish girl
what's wrong with him
what's wrong with her I really wish I
had a map right about now your fears
kicking in it's okay good I thought that
means Jason's near if that just means
like that happens occasionally now that
you're like well it depends on her
composure I think she's probably got
pretty low composure
I think hers was like five out of ten
maybe not bad okay uh insidiously says
health sprays are usually in bathrooms
yeah I found that earlier the first one
in the bathroom who everyone is over
there for whatever reason I wish I could
see it better not escape with healthy Oh
might have to swim across no there's a
little bridge or something
Oh through here yeah
drive by Jason with the shotgun I would
oh there's the other car you got the key
I have the key can't leave without you
how many I feel bad for that person we
met cuz they probably had the key was
really stoked about it and then got
killed right I got the keys sorry I
can't I can't talk to you right now
don't talk but we totally had the keys
man oh dude there's a Jason Jason's
right there come on Joey no no the car
is not ready yet car is not fixed do not
use that key do not do not let them
drive away without you okay
she's also someone's definitely dad no
not yet i man they're really free of
them there alright let's get into these
houses and look for first aid
okay close that door good call yeah no
it's just you want to hide oh no yeah
like how doesn't when they they just
burst out though the closet yeah that's
that's not suspicious oh you're in
trouble dude this might be it Joey
no it's not it's not it's not it watch
see this right here
oh don't set it down I hate that it's oh
yeah I always have the wrong button
okay you know put it down right here no
there's a knife pick up that knife you
took can you not there yeah there we go
now remember when you leave yeah I gotta
go out a different way oh that's a
machete not a knife
oh wait you stopped the flare though
right oh it's right there yeah you want
the flare instead the player at the
flare is better okay what guy was out
the window
whoops no come on I don't think he's
coming in here
he I was just bust through that yeah put
I got the window I can hear the music
though he knows he doesn't know I mean
he could have just teleport around like
near the car cuz he knows that there's
other people there
oh okay I'm getting out of here remember
I am stealth him stealth incarnate
well the doors open here
I'll stop screaming
[Music]
guys I have the queue there I fear is
acting up again
woohee already came through here
something good something good yes we got
the map at least thank you
good wrench looks like this place been
picked clean otherwise oh dude oh nice
you didn't hit him in the face though
what's he gonna do huh
a candy cane er this is one of the new
outfits yes
so watch go here and then just go hmm
wait
you
he's good yeah he probably went
somewhere else he's right there on the
map okay yeah now he's you're going
towards him the ways that percent of a
gas can
that's Nick Nick Nick Nick we got the
key Nick you're watching the stream we
have the key also if we die we have the
key so take it off our body recycle
wolfies room everyone's just running
quite a bit in this this round I'm
amazed how much we've all lasted though
yo Nick we got the key we have the key
who has a battery please say it in the
chat cuz two minutes yeah you could also
just try to hold out yeah we could
crap how many are left three eight all
crap
no don't bring them here it's like a
wolf take one for the team man oh dude
oh no hey it's a Nick I have nothing to
save them with sorry Oh Nick we
apologize you can hear it I'm not
watching though sorry Nick so close -
that's right you tell him psycho wolf go
after him oh he probably hit him with a
bat or something
I'm staying around she's like a fish the
way her mouth moves like though Oh hers
sick she's a you know breathing oxygen
mm-hmm who got a life preserver maybe
this will help me survive go swim oh
come on no you had the flare gun Lowell
no no no we use the fire museu uh do
they know they can't hide when feared oh
maybe not so I'm currently one who
figured hiding doesn't really I mean is
work so far yeah I know it still hasn't
noticed us okay okay good it's like a
wolf is still alive good we're looking
okay yeah we survived the night take it
Oh Jason it's not done we talking about
return
that's your mom's head
all right like we're we're gonna call
here yeah does he survive the final
Jason we did it we got we got a couple
good ones some good blasts this is Chad
feed add face oh it's the that's the guy
that's table why do I get a badge for
that that's why I want to know okay
question you look it up um yeah I think
this was a pretty good idea of what this
update has to offer
yeah like it's still little I still want
that 13,000 uh customization points
right should be this later um seems like
the servers are still a little buggy um
Nick got kicked a couple times Jake
seemed to have no luck getting into all
yeah which is a bummer so what's the
check what's the Chad face oh it was the
badge right here badge reach 100 fear
and still survive all right
okay I got to it yeah all right so yeah
everyone that was fried 13th a good time
with that no yeah
enjoyed it we're gonna have another
stream later at 2:00 for next machina
with Jake so that should be pretty good
yeah are you gonna be on there as well I
think so yeah so streams good deal it's
very good game I played a little bit
last night and I was surprised how much
I enjoyed it so definitely check that
out and yeah we'll have a more stuff
going up on YouTube we get a couple of
stragglers from e3 going up throughout
the week um and yeah for more make sure
to subscribe and stay tuned thanks for
watching guys see you